welcome to this video playing swap from
Germany and it's a queen's gambit this
is international master mullah if I'm
right matey's Miller from Germany they
are blatant numerous times of the young
and I don't think my results were that
great very resourceful defender okay
doing further Slovaks change I have some
ideas with queen bee three it's a very
solid line on the slim white um normally
maintains a very miniscule edge but it's
a very very miniscule okay let's see if
I can at least provoke him to to take
with the pawn
this is the game kramnik Arnold first
game of the bond match that's like
that's possible somehow I found a vague
recollection of this kind of idea yeah
he really wants to go to take here with
the with the rook yeah maybe i can after
roxy six-play night h6 but he's not even
allowing that I go here this Queen a
five okay if I go here group takes Queen
B seven win a five yeah boy don't I is
playing everything instantly great are
we really representing this game it's
possible if i take here this rocks you
one okay i need to take now Brooks him
on this big threat some castles yeah I
her born up but he's got the C file and
he played everything absolutely
instantly so on it seems that this is in
fact the theoretically explored position
maybe really this the Sun Cromley
gallant game it's at least a very very
similar type type of position
okay how to i want to get ahead to you
hmm yeah very tricky to make any
progress IAM before he put something on
the beef oh yeah maybe anyway I don't
know but some probably impossible to
really to really get them get something
here can't preparing before
okay Bishop c7 maybe rook takes rookie
too ok let's try that at least I'm i was
able to get rid of the opposite colored
bishops and I'm keeping the pawn if I'm
able to yeah yeah I am is some trying to
activate
and trying to switch attention to the
deep on so we switch or we exchange be
poured upon check
check
hmm
I can be five he's gotta leave five yeah
y'all for the draw
it will bite the white is somewhat
better here but 40 seconds is it's not
much yeah maybe I should have taken it
check yeah okay it's just the wrong game
drawn maybe I could have done something
I wrote here I think what has
substantial winning chances I've got the
King involved and this should be very
much better for white but probably I
need some more precision yeah yeah it is
Rocky III Rocky III intending King to d2
yeah this is very very good for night
I'm able to get rid of his active rook
here let's say something like that if he
retreats I can exchange this off at this
is really a weakness this pawn yeah
quite good for what I can take and play
that maybe maybe this is something yeah
but this is still a weakness this poem
yeah white has good winning chances like
like has some some resources to defend
but why this very much better and some
that's tricky to defend really yeah okay
so this was to check to to settle
probably
yeah well this is just just the draw I
don't have the database available at the
moment but this is really very similar
to this on Crowley game Kramnik on our
first match game it bond maybe some of
you can I can can check this if this is
really the game as possible it was very
close at least alright thanks for
watching